Trascrizione: Matteo Maggiò
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Sapete perché sono qui?
Sono qui perché sono finito in galera.
A 60 anni, da incensurato,
ho commesso un reato, grave;
e mi sono costituito.
Con le mie lauree,
con le mie pubblicazioni scientifiche,
i miei brevetti,
le mie partecipazioni
ai congressi internazionali,
i miei viaggi intorno al mondo,
sono finito dentro.
E sono finito in carcere
convintissimo di sapere
ciò che avrei trovato,
perché di detenzione mi ero
occupato tantissimo,
anche se non era il mio mestiere:
io sono un fisico.
Ma avevo letto tanti libri,
anche specialistici, di sociologia;
ho visto film, documentari, interviste.
Credevo di essere
perfettamente a conoscenza
di cosa fosse la detenzione:
e soprattutto, ero convintissimo di sapere
quale fosse il grave problema
del carcere italiano.
Ovvio: il problema è la carenza
di diritti umani dei detenuti.
I detenuti sono trattati in modo inumano.
Questa è una cosa che condividono
in tanti, in Italia - non tantissimi.
Sono in tanti ad essere
convinti di questo:
che i detenuti siano trattati
in maniera disumana.
Tantissimi di più
sono convinti del contrario,
che i detenuti siano trattati troppo bene:
pane, acqua e buttare via la chiave!
Bene, io sono stato in carcere
e ho cambiato idea.
Ma non perché non ci siano violazioni
dei diritti umani, tutt'altro:
il carcere è un posto tremendo,
e non è un caso se i detenuti
si uccidono, e si suicidano,
venti volte più che non in libertà.
Venti volte!
E quando non riescono a suicidarsi
si tagliano, si infliggono
delle mutilazioni,
sbattono la testa al muro,
soprattutto i più deboli.
Per loro il carcere è un inferno.
Dunque, i diritti umani
non vengono rispettati.
Ma se dico che non è questo il problema,
allora il problema qual è?
Il problema è che il carcere non funziona.
A che cosa serve il carcere?
Cosa dovrebbe fare il carcere?
Ce lo dice la nostra Costituzione:
"Le pene devono tendere
alla rieducazione del condannato",
che è una cosa logica:
Hai violato la legge?
Bisogna comminarti una pena:
ma a cosa deve servire la pena?
A farti ridiventare una persona onesta.
Così ti fai i tuoi anni,
dopodiché finisci la pena
e rientri nella società
come una persona normale,
come una persona onesta.
Il carcere fa questa cosa?
Ma assolutamente no!
Recidiva al 70%: cosa vuol dire?
Che su ogni dieci detenuti
che scontano la pena in carcere,
sette escono, delinquono di nuovo
e ritornano in carcere.
Ogni 100 detenuti, 70 escono,
e ritornano in carcere
perché hanno commesso altri reati;
ogni 1000, 700 ritornano;
ogni 10.000,
7000 escono, commettono dei delitti
e ritornano in carcere.
In carcere ci sono
dalle 50.000 alle 60.000 persone.
Facciamoci un po' di conti:
e quanto ci costa?
Ci costa tre miliardi di euro all'anno!
Per me, che ho 70 anni,
sono seimila miliardi delle vecchie lire:
un tempo, con una cifra del genere,
si faceva una finanziaria.
E allora?
Ma possibile?
Perché non li rieduchiamo?
Perché spendiamo questi soldi
per prendere dei delinquenti,
lasciarli un po' di tempo in carcere,
tirarli fuori ancora delinquenti
in maniera tale che poi
li dobbiamo ancora arrestare,
spendere un sacco di soldi
e rimettere dentro?
Ma non si potrebbe educarli?
Certo, ma a questo punto la domanda è:
ma questi signori
vogliono essere educati o no?
Sarà possibile rieducare un delinquente?
Oppure non c'è niente da fare,
e per i delinquenti, 7000 ogni 10.000
restano delinquenti?
Per rispondere a questa domanda,
partirò da una cosa importantissima:
da un paio di mutande sporche.
Io sono entrato in carcere
alle due del mattino,
ed erano due giorni che viaggiavo.
Quando sono entrato in carcere,
mi hanno fatto allungare le braccia
e sul braccio mi hanno messo:
una coperta; due lenzuola; una federa;
due ciotole d'acciaio,
come quelle che si usano
per dare da mangiare e da bere ai cani;
una forchetta e un cucchiaio di alluminio;
un bicchiere di plastica;
una minuscola saponetta da hotel;
uno spazzolino usa e getta,
e un tubetto di dentifricio
che si esauriva in una volta.
In cella, avevo un gran bisogno
di lavarmi e di cambiarmi;
Ma alle due del mattino,
non c'è acqua calda.
E poi, non in tutte le celle
c'è la doccia;
anzi, nella maggior parte dei casi
c'è la doccia di reparto.
La doccia di reparto
la si usa nel giorno della doccia:
per cui, se sei fortunato,
e finisci in cella
nel giorno della doccia,
ti fai la doccia;
se no, aspetti il giorno dopo -
o due giorni dopo, chi lo sa -
nel giorno della doccia.
Ma se anche avessi avuto
la possibilità di farla, questa doccia,
come mi sarei dovuto asciugare?
Ricordate forse che vi ho detto
che mi hanno dato un asciugamano?
No.
Mi hanno dato dello shampoo? No.
Mi hanno dato della biancheria
di ricambio? No!
Alle sei del mattino -
non ero mai stato in carcere -
chiedo al poliziotto di turno:
- "Mi scusi, ma come faccio
a lavarmi? - "Ci penso io!"
E se ne va, e torna dopo due minuti,
con questo, con un modulo:
la domandina semplice,
il cuore del carcere,
modello 393 della
Amministrazione Penitenziaria.
Se sei un detenuto,
e vuoi esercitare un diritto,
devi compilare il modulo
e consegnarlo al poliziotto,
il quale lo prende e lo mette in tasca.
Naturalmente, questo signore
stava per darmelo.
Poi mi ha guardato - io ero allibito -
e allora si è rivolto a un altro detenuto.
Gli ha detto: "Senti,
questo non sa come si fa:
fallo tu per lui.
E questo poverino,
che scriveva a malapena,
ci ha scritto:
"Io sottoscritto, Sergio Abis,
chiedo di andare alla Caritas,
perché non ho niente".
E lì ho imparato la prima lezione:
il carcere mi stava educando.
Effettivamente, il carcere educa:
se hai bisogno di qualcosa,
non ti rivolgere al poliziotto,
non ti rivolgere allo Stato,
perché tanto il poliziotto ti manda
da un delinquente come te.
Questa domandina non funziona:
è chiaro, che non funziona.
È un metodo per levarsi dalle tasche
tutti quei detenuti che continuano
a chiedere chi una cosa chi l'altra:
tanto si sa, più o meno,
quello che si può ottenere.
E infatti, io che cosa ho fatto?
Andare alla Caritas
non è compilare la domandina,
e un'ora dopo andare alla Caritas.
Come c'è il giorno della doccia,
c'è il giorno della Caritas:
che può capitare una volta alla settimana,
una volta ogni dieci giorni,
una volta al mese - chi lo sa?
E non è che, perché hai fatto
la domanda, ci vai.
Hai fatto la domanda, ti metti in fila:
magari c'è una fila lunghissima.
In carcere, tutti hanno
bisogno della Caritas.
E se avessi dovuto aspettare un mese?
C'è chi ha aspettato un mese,
per avere un asciugamano.
Cosa ho fatto?
Sono andato da un ragazzo che collaborava
con la distribuzione della Caritas,
e gli ho detto:
"Senti, io ho bisogno di lavarmi.
Mi puoi dare una mano?"
- "Ti do una mano".
E mi ha fatto saltare la fila:
una settimana dopo avevo l'asciugamano
e il cambio di biancheria,
un paio di ciabatte per fare la doccia,
un paio di scarpe - di pessima qualità,
ma meglio di niente -
e una tuta, tre taglie
più grande della mia.
Perché li ho avuti?
Perché ho imbrogliato!
C'era qualcuno che aveva
più diritto di me;
lui non si è lavato; io sì.
Il carcere è tutto così.
Hai bisogno di mangiare?
Ti devi mettere d'accordo
con altri delinquenti per mangiare,
se non hai soldi per pagartelo.
Che cosa vuol dire, questo?
Chi mi ha mandato dall'altro delinquente?
Mi ha mandato il poliziotto!
Il poliziotto cosa ti dice,
quando entri in carcere?
"Siete tutti delinquenti:
mettetevi d'accordo,
basta che non vi ammazziate tra di voi,
che non ci ammazziate, non vi ammazziate;
per il resto, arrangiatevi."
Chi entra in carcere,
non fa altro che fare
una vita da delinquente
insieme ad altri delinquenti:
e te lo dicono proprio loro, i poliziotti!
Chiedi a lui, lui non sa come si fa:
ma pensaci tu che lo sai.
Può sembrare una sciocchezza, ma -
e se quel ragazzo
che mi ha fatto saltare la fila,
in modo tale che qualcun altro,
che aveva più diritto di me,
non si è lavato, e io sì,
mi avesse detto: "Senti, guarda:
io ti ho fatto il favore,
ma tu me lo ricambi.
Le vedi queste cinque bustine?
Quando vai a prenderti l'asciugamano,
consegnale a quel ragazzo
che ti da l'asciugamano".
Io avrei potuto dire di no?
Ma no che non avrei potuto, ma quando mai?
Il carcere è fatto così.
Se non sei un delinquente
farai bene a diventarlo,
e anche in fretta:
perché se non diventi
un delinquente in fretta,
cosa ho detto, prima?
Ci si ammazza 20 volte di più
che in libertà.
Ora, ma non è una cosa idiota?
Cioè, noi spendiamo tre miliardi di euro
per prendere dei delinquenti -
che sono delinquenti,
quindi vanno in carcere;
poi facciamo in maniera
che diventino ancora più delinquenti,
o comunque restino delinquenti come erano.
Dopo di che li tiriamo fuori,
e ci stupiamo se ogni mille delinquenti
settecento sono ancora delinquenti?
Ma dovremmo stupirci di quei trenta,
o trecento, o tremila,
che invece non lo sono!
Perché il carcere ti costringe
ad essere delinquente:
Non ci sono vie d'uscita?
Io sono - in carcere,
ho avuto paura come tutti:
ma il sentimento più profondo
era una terribile rabbia, una stizza.
Pensavo: ma si può essere così idioti?
Spendiamo tre miliardi di euro
per generare degli altri delinquenti,
che vanno e continuano
a fare i delinquenti!
Non ci sarà una soluzione?
Avevo appena finito di scontare la pena,
che ricevo una telefonata.
Un prete di Cagliari
mi dice: "Ciao, Sergio.
Sai, io ho fondato da 25 anni
una comunità di recupero per detenuti.
Anziché scontare la pena in carcere,
questi vengono e scontano la pena da me.
E non sono ladri di polli:
sono assassini - efferati assassini;
sono stupratori;
sono quelli che insidiano
i bambini, i pedofili.
Eppure, su cento che vengono da me,
soltanto quattro delinquono di nuovo".
Io gli ho detto: "Ma mi
stai dicendo quattro, o 40?",
Perché ero abituato al 70.
"No, quattro: e secondo me,
siccome ci conoscono in pochi,
sarebbe bene che ci
conoscessero un po' di più.
Ho pensato che sarebbe bello
scrivere un libro:
perché non lo scrivi tu?
Conosci già il carcere, vieni da noi,
stai un po' con noi,
così vedi come lavoriamo
e scrivi un libro".
Cioè, mi stava chiedendo
di tornare in galera:
perché lui la chiama "la comunità",
ma quei detenuti lì non sono liberi, eh.
La galera è un posto dove non si è liberi:
e lì, non sono liberi.
Per farla breve, ho preso un aereo,
sono andato da loro, sono stato un po',
e li, ho scritto questo libro.
Non ne posso parlare troppo,
ma lasciatemi dire
che si intitola "Chi sbaglia paga",
perché io sono convintissimo
che chi commette un delitto
debba rimettersi a posto con la società.
E il sottotitolo del libro
è, anche, "Certezza della pena -",
perché secondo me
la pena va scontata tutta -
ma "Certezza della pena
e della rieducazione".
Perché voi potete dare
tutti gli anni che volete a un detenuto;
ma se non lo rieducate,
tutti quegli anni non servono a niente.
Perché se lui esce,
ed è ancora un delinquente,
gli potete dare dieci anni, 12, 15 anche,
per aver rubato una gallina.
Bene, tanto dopo 15 anni
avete tra i piedi
ancora un altro delinquente.
Come funziona questo posto?
Nel carcere, quello che ho fatto io,
non si lavora: si ozia.
Ma non perché i detenuti
non vogliano lavorare:
non si lavora perché non è possibile,
perché il carcere non è previsto
per avere dei lavoratori.
Solo il tre percento delle ore
possibilmente sfruttabili in carcere
viene usato per lavorare.
E se non si lavora, cosa si fa?
Si acquisiscono pessime abitudini:
ci si corica alle tre del mattino,
ci si alza alle 11:30:
tanto, non c'è niente da fare.
In questo altro carcere, invece,
si entra soltanto se si lavora:
per cui, è impossibile
avere cattive abitudini.
E gli orari sono scanditi dal lavoro,
come capita per tutti noi che lavoriamo.
La mattina ci si alza,
e siccome lì i detenuti lavorano
in una tenuta agricola,
vanno a lavorare nei campi.
Ritornano, preparano il pranzo,
lavano i piatti;
di pomeriggio, vanno a lavorare nei campi.
Televisione praticamente non ce n'è:
perché la sera, quando si torna,
si è stanchi: bisogna fare la cena.
Forse una mezz'oretta, dopocena.
Mai televisione accesa durante i pasti:
si parla, si interagisce.
In carcere, si mangia a spese dello Stato:
siccome non si lavora,
non si ha un reddito.
La maggior parte della gente
in carcere non ha una lira -
pardon, non ha un euro -
e quindi sono mantenuti dallo Stato.
E per questo, si mendica
un paio di mutande:
"Voglio andare alla Caritas"
Qui, si paga il proprio mantenimento:
ciascun detenuto ha uno stipendio,
il 30% lo versa nella cassa comune,
e mangia.
Quindi non c'è qualcuno
che gli dà da mangiare:
si paga il cibo.
E guarda un po',
ci si compra un paio di mutande.
Non c'è bisogno di andare alla Caritas,
non c'è bisogno di andare dal detenuto
e dirgli: "Per favore, fammi saltare la-".
Si fa una vita normale.
E ci si basa sui rapporti di forza,
e si obbedisce agli ordini del più forte.
In carcere, si ha paura
del detenuto più cattivo di te;
ma si ha paura anche del poliziotto.
È per quello, che in carcere
si sta tranquilli:
si vive nella paura, tra delinquenti.
E in questo carcere,
si aderisce al convincimento
dell'educatore.
L'educatore, in questo carcere qua,
è un collega di lavoro.
Chi va in questo carcere,
fa parte di una cooperativa
di cui fa parte anche l'educatore.
L'educatore, la mattina,
non si limita a dare ordini,
come farebbe un poliziotto in carcere.
Dice: guarda, oggi andiamo
a potare le viti.
Prendiamo le cesoie, hai le tue cesoie?
- Sì. - Andiamo, guarda: si fa così:
e lavorano assieme.
Poi resta un educatore, poi si obbedisce;
ma il rapporto è completamente diverso.
In carcere si è chiusi in gabbia;
e nell'altro carcere non ci sono chiavi.
Perché non ci sono chiavi?
Perché per entrare lì,
uno deve auto convincersi
di dover scontare una pena,
quindi non fugge.
In 30 anni, in quel carcere
non c'è mai stato
un solo tentativo di fuga.
E naturalmente, nel carcere "contenitivo"
non c'è attività culturale: ma quando mai?
Non si fa niente.
In quest'altro carcere, invece,
si partecipa attivamente
ad attività culturali:
sono fondamentali per la rieducazione.
E naturalmente, nel carcere normale
c'è poca interazione sociale:
con chi interagisce il delinquente?
Con altri delinquenti,
oppure con i poliziotti.
E invece, qua no:
proprio per le attività culturali,
c'è un sacco di gente
che va in quel carcere lì.
Poi, i detenuti restano dentro:
ma conoscono un sacco di gente.
E naturalmente, in carcere
c'è la violazione dei diritti umani.
Come sarebbe possibile altrimenti?
Prendete un cumulo di delinquenti,
li mettete assieme,
li fate guardare a vista dai poliziotti:
come si fa a non avere violazioni?
E qui no, invece:
perché il rispetto dei diritti umani
è una parte della rieducazione.
Per finire,
perché il carcere non funziona?
Perché è pieno di poliziotti:
c'è un poliziotto ogni due detenuti,
e un'educatore ogni 80;
ma in certe carceri
è un educatore ogni 200.
Mentre in quest'altro carcere qui
non ci sono i poliziotti,
e c'è un educatore ogni due detenuti.
Ecco perché li rieducano:
perché è un carcere fatto per rieducare!
E guarda un po', il carcere normale
costa 140€ al giorno per detenuto,
e questo costa la metà: 70€.
Recidiva [del] 70 percento;
recidiva [del] quattro.
Questo non è un miracolo:
è semplicemente un carcere
fatto per educare,
che dimostra che è possibile
rieducare i carcerati.
E in definitiva, qualunque sia
il vostro orientamento politico,
chiedete ai vostri rappresentanti -
quelli che votate -
un carcere che funzioni.
Cioè che punisca rieducando,
secondo Costituzione:
non come quello attuale, che non rieduca.
E se vi diranno che non è possibile,
dite loro che non è vero:
perché c'è chi da 30 anni lo fa,
e lo fa anche bene,
spendendo la metà.
E rispettando i diritti umani.
Grazie.
(Applausi)